Thank you again for the invitation and to talk about Krenolanib.
So this is the result of the ARO013 clinical trial evaluating Krenolanib plus intensive chemo in relapsed refractory EML.
So as you know, Krenolanib is a type 1, 3 inhibitor.
So in the AIML in vitro assay, we observed a big sensitivity of Krenolanib for leukemic blasts with a flat rate mutation.
And we also observed a highly active activity, again, blasts with a co-occurring mutation, NPM1, DNMT3A, TET2, and WT1.
As you can see on the right, patient mutations.
So patients who are mutated with FLT3 and NPM1 have a very high sensitivity with Krenolanib.
So what we know about Krenolanib?
So this is a high sensitivity drug for FLT3-mutated EML.
We know that the Krenolanib does not accumulate.
And there is a similar drug level after day 1 to day 15.
There is favorable pharmacological properties with a short half time, 6 to 8 hours.
No significant drug-drug interaction.
And there is no QT prolongation.
So today there is a big experience with Krenolanib.
There is 375 patients.
Already treated with Krenolanib in clinical trial.
And the background of this study presented here was the phase 1 and phase 2 study, RO010 and RO011 study.
Where was evaluated a full dose of Krenolanib combined with intensive chemo.
And the combination was safe.
And we observed 67% of overall results.
67% of overall response rate in relapsed refractory FLT3-mutated EML.
So this is the design of the clinical trial.
So it was a randomized clinical trial, a one-to-one.
Comparing salvaged chemo, flag-AIDA or AM, plus Krenolanib versus flag-AIDA or AM plus placebo.
The population was relapsed refractory, high-cute myeloid leukemia.
Patient could have TKI treatment in first or second line.
And of course, all patients were mutated for FLT3.
So 106 patients were included in this clinical trial.
The median age was 55.
And 38% of patients
were more than 60 years old.
93% of patients were mutated for FLT3 at Baseline.
And 56% had co-occurring NPM1 mutations.
So 100% of patients progressed after receiving intensive chemo in this clinical trial.
27% progressed after two prior chemotherapy regimens.
And 25% relapsed after prior allogeneic stem cell transplantation.
This is a population already exposed to FLT3 inhibitors.
So 69% of patients already received at least one prior FLT3 TKI before entering in the trial.
The majority was Midosterine.
Some was Giltaritinib, usually at salvage as a second line.
And few received Quisartinib and Sorafenib.
So we observe in terms of response a significant increase of the overall response rate.
So 39% to 60% using Crenolanib plus intensive chemo.
So there is an increase in terms of response rate.
But also a significant increase in terms of CRI.
The primary endpoint of the study was the event-free survival.
And we observe a significant increase of event-free survival in this clinical trial.
There is a big improvement from 0 months to 3.4 months.
And in a post-hoc analysis,
in patients commutated for NPM1 and FLT3,
it was 59 patients.
We observe also a significant increase in terms of event-free survival,
but also in terms of overall survival.
So for the overall survival,
we observe an increase of 6 months to 12 months
using Crenolanib plus intensive chemo.
For the patient breached to transplant after intensive chemo plus Crenolanib,
as you can see,
we observe also a significant increase in terms of overall survival
after halostem cell transplantation.
We could use Crenolanib as maintenance after halostem cell transplantation.
In this specific clinical trial,
and you can see for the patient treated with salvage chemo plus Crenolanib,
the median overall survival was not rich.
In terms of safety,
so we observe the same safety already observed in the other clinical trial.
So the drug was manageable.
The main side effect was the GI toxicity.
GI toxicity with nausea and diarrhea.
But you can see this is manageable.
This is more a grade 1 and grade 2 severity.
So to conclude,
so this is the first randomized trial demonstrating the benefits
to add 3TKI to intensive chemo
in this specific setting in relapsed refractory EML.
This is the first randomized trial showing also that we can use
a new 3TKI after a first one and two increased survival.
And there is a specific benefit in subpopulation mutated
with NPM1 and FLT3 mutation.
So I would like to thank all the patients and family
and all investigators implicated in this study.
Thank you for your attention.